hey excuse me give me back my mask no
give me back my man oh hey
mother what is this what's gonna like it
here I can't see in this thing what
where are you
What did he say you know hey you stole
my mask no I didn't yes you did you know
we can barely hear you with the cone on
your head if you know mine if you would
[Applause]
the real spider-man I
I happen to be a very big fan of
spider-man how did he steal your mass
it's a long story Jimmy it's a sad story
too I ran out of web fluid I was waiting
for the be 38 and he snuck up behind me
and stole it right off my head he snuck
up behind you but I thought you had
spidey sense and that's for threats
oh and he's not really all that
threatening that's good
can I just have my mask back so we can
get back to set come on give them back
his mask this is ridiculous you don't
steal masks from Heroes thank you so
much
all right smells really weird that's
tequila
oh it's tequila but did you see you have
to get back to set yeah are you making
another movie spider-man far from home
next is this is this movie a prequel
because you know in the end of infinity
war you turn into like black confetti
Santos is robbing a bank so I'm gonna go
in well why would Dan'l's rob a bank
that doesn't this sense
Santos is poor
[Applause]
everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new spider-man to break down
both spider-man far from home and
spider-man into the spider verse because
they dropped that post Malone trailer
with a whole bunch of new footage so
I'll talk about the Tom Hollands stuff
first because that's happening later
tonight then I'll talk about the new
spider-verse footage there's a new round
of that spider-man ps4 game giveaway too
just because all this spider-man stuff
is going on all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a
spider-man related comment on the video
the reason why Tom Holland is going on
jimmy kimmel in his new suit is
obviously to promo the movie and tell
everybody what's going on I don't think
that they're gonna be dropping a big
trailer or anything like that I think
he's just gonna be talking about the
suit and what's going on with the movie
whatever that ends up being I will
totally do a video for it it is really
late so that video won't post til Friday
morning no worries about that but I do
like how he tries to skirt around
explaining the snap sure and infinity
war shouldn't you be dead right now is
this movie not gonna be a prequel he
just mumbles as he runs off camera and
does a flip so if you were wondering why
Tom Holland was teasing him going back
in the makeup chair earlier today on his
Instagram this is what that is for the
brand new footage for spider-man into
the spider verse was for the post Malone
music video that they dropped a little
while to go to I'm shameik Moore I'm
Jack Johnson and I've voiced Mouse
Morales and I voiced Peter Parker in
spider-man into the spider first brought
you a sneak peek from our upcoming movie
there's only one spider-man but there's
another you
like me spider-verse is the first movie
about a biracial superhero Wow miles has
got to learn from the more experienced
spider people so you want to learn to be
spider-man no I have to learn to be
spider-man one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you just
film has crazy cool action this is gonna
take spider-man to a whole new level
[Music]
morning I woke up in a
you
[Applause]
there are a couple new plot points that
we haven't seen in the earlier trailers
so at the beginning of the film miles
gets in to a special magnet school it's
a big deal so like you see him here
getting ready and going to his first day
of school it's supposed to be a really
big deal because they come from a really
low income area and he winds up winning
the lottery to get into this special
school so it means it's really good
education meaning that he could follow
in Peter Parker's track someday and
become a scientist just like him there's
a lot of awkward romance stuff going on
with Gwen Stacy it's not spider-gwen
though because then the other trailer
spider-gwen says we need to get back to
our own universes so this version is
just totally normal gwen stacy they just
have that awkward interaction like you
would see with Peter Parker in high
school
Tom Holland did the exact same thing
during the homecoming movie where by the
end of the movie he finally got the
courage to ask out Liz who he had had a
crush on for a long time they went to
homecoming together obviously didn't go
down the way he expected but I'm
expecting a similar twist with Myles and
Gwen Stacy where he's all awkward and
nerdy at the beginning of the film then
by the end of the film he goes through
all those adventures with midlifecrisis
Peter Parker Gwen Stacy from another
universe and finally gets the courage to
ask his version of Gwen Stacy out but
the other thing that we learned about
this version of Peter Parker he
definitely doesn't sound like 6-1-6
Peter Parker once you hear his backstory
Jake Johnson literally called him
midlife crisis Peter Parker he used to
be married to Mary Jane Parker but his
life of fighting crime just was terrible
for their marriage so she left him so
he's been on his own he's kind of let
himself go he's got a bit of a beer gut
so this movie is a bit of a call to
action for him so because his life is so
[ __ ] in the universe that he comes from
that's why I'm pretty sure that this is
not gonna be 6-1-6 Peter Parker he'll be
from some other universe because that
would be the most sad version of Peter
Parker ever now obviously the one on
miles is earth is ultimate Peter Parker
part of the footage is actually just the
venom post-credit scene with post Malone
song on top of it where they have the
really awkward run-in at ultimate Peter
Parker's grave the Jake Johnson Peter
Parker is trying to introduce himself
for the first time and everybody freaks
out and they wind up crashing their way
down the street so if you guys haven't
seen it what I'm expecting is is that
regardless of what Tom Holland brings
with him in terms of previews or footage
or whatever to Jimmy Kimmel tonight they
will probably attach the first genuine
teaser trailer for spider-man far from
home - into the spider verse in the
middle of December so no worries we'll
have all kinds of spider-man's stuff to
talk about tomorrow there was a lot of
debate going on yesterday about what
color exactly that suit is because it
kind of looks black in this light here
but if you're looking at it out close it
really does look dark blue
hopefully they'll clarify a little bit
about what's going on with that and
obviously they're probably gonna try to
avoid giving away spoilers about
Avengers 4 and how everybody comes back
because very clearly spider-man has to
come back to make this movie post all
your theories in the comments below that
new spider-man Jimmy Kimmel video will
be up Friday morning
while you wait for everything click here
for more spider-man far from home and
click here for the new Captain Marvel
trailer and learn all about how Marvel
changed her backstory for the MCU ahead
of Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]